- I heard you took a very different
approach to writing this record.
You kind of like went off the grid, right?
- Yeah.
- So I-
- Like how off the grid?
- I was heavily on all the
social media and everything,
and just constantly on my phone.
And I was like, I gotta just
step away from everything,
take some time for myself.
I got a flip phone.
- A flip phone, like?
- Yeah, I mean, straight
up hang up on somebody
and close it, you know?
Make a point kind of-
- The only thing better would
have been a beeper, but okay.
- Yeah, that's next.
That's my next stage for my next album.
But it just really made me kinda
focus on myself for a while
and just kinda figure
out what I wanted to say,
who I wanted to be, and
started journaling a lot more.
I got a Polaroid camera,
was taking photos,
actually making everyone count.
Every picture wasn't perfect.
You know, when you have a phone,
you can take 4,000 pictures and pick one.
It's like Polaroid, you've
gotta make that moment count.
So just doing stuff
like that really made me
reflective of my life, where I was
and where I am and where
I wanna go with it.
- Slow down and appreciate it.
- Slow it down, yeah.
- So I think that's why
I love this record so much.
- There's never a moment for yourself.
- It feels real, like a real album.
- Yes, well thank you.
- Yeah, and actually, I
think it was Blake or Gwen,
one of them, was the one who
turned me on to it at first.
And I was like, oh, I was
like, I gotta check that out.
But it's really well done as an album,
it sounds like an album.
- Well, thank you.
- Yeah.
- I appreciate that.